يزداد الانقسام الاوروبي بشان فرض سعر
للغاز الطبيعي تتباين الاراء حول الامر
منذ بدايات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا ويفرد
الامر نفسه الان بشده مع حلول فصل الشتاء
حاليا من خلال مفاوضات الدول الاتحاد
الاوروبي الرابيه لوضع اتفاق لاسعار الغاز
خلال الاجتماع المقرر لوزراء الطاقه يوم
الثلاثاء القادم
12 دوله بين هذا بلجيكا وايطاليا وبولندا
تسعى عليه راي خفض كبير لسقف الاتحاد
المزمار لاسعار الغاز وتطالب مقترحاتها
بان يكون الحد الاقصى للسعر اقل كثيرا عن
احدث مستوى تتفاوض الدول بشانه من الناحيه
الثانيه فان صوت الدول المعارضه لهذا
الاقتراح وبينها المانيا يبدو اعلى وتطرح
هذه الدول مقترحات اخرى بينها ضروره ان
يضمن اي ت باستمرار الاسعار في اطار
تنافسي مع بقيه الدول العالم
لكن يبدو ان كل هذه الاقتراحات قابله
للتغيير قبل او اثناء اجتماعي وزراء
الطاقه الاوروبيين يوم الثلاثاء المقبل
وكان الاجتماع السابق للوزراء اواخر
نوفمبر الماضي قد فشل في الاتفاق على وضع
حد اقصى لاسعار الغاز الروسيه في هذه
الاثناء يحذر البنك المركزي الاوروبي من
انهيار الاستقرار المالي والانعكاسات
السالبه التي قد تترتب على تحديد السقف
لاسعار الغاز الطبيعي على مستوى الاتحاد
الاوروبي ولا يخفي قلبه من شان المخاطر
المحتمله على مدمن الاسواق الماليه
الاوروبيه روسيه تراقب الموقف بحذر وتعتقد
موسكو ان اي تحديدا باسعار الغاز سيكبد
اوروبا خسائر كبيره ويقول نائب وزير
الخارجيه الروسي سيرجي
على اتخاذ التدابير اللازمه للحد من
العواقب مشددا على ان على الغرب الاستعداد
للرد الروسي في حال الاقتراب من اسعار
غازها الطبيعي عموما يعتقد كثيرون ان
اوروبا وان تمكنت من ربح حرب الغاز
الحاليه واتازت الشتاء الراهن بسلام فان
الازمه تظل هاجسا كبيرا تعيشه دول الاتحاد
ولو بمستويات مختلفه ويتعين عليها البحث
عن سبل ضمان استمرار امدادات الغاز
مستقبلا بما يضمن لها تفوقا على المدى
الطويل لا يجزم بامكانيه حدوثه احد